in New Zealand this morning we're
learning the names of some of the
victims of the volcanic eruption there
47 people including nine Americans were
on white island at the time of the
disaster web cam footage shows people
walking inside the crater this is just
moments before the eruption happened
Ramey Inocencio is near the scene in New
Zealand ramie good morning what's the
status of the rescue operation good
morning I'm standing right by this
makeshift memorial for those people who
died really just off the coast the death
toll stands as the six people are now
confirmed dead eight people are still
missing but those people are also
believed to have been killed at the same
time New Zealand police had are trying
to get out to white Island but they say
conditions are still just too dangerous
[Music]
during their rush to escape tourists
shot video of white Island moments after
it blasted open the violent eruption
sent plumes of searing hot smoke and ash
more than 12,000 feet into the air New
Zealand's Prime Minister just in to our
turn address Parliament Tuesday police
and Defence Force personnel have
undertaken a number of aerial
reconnaissance flights over the islands
since the eruption however no signs of
life have been detected New Zealand
Police say they have photo showing the
location of six unidentified bodies that
are still trapped on the island covered
in ash unstable conditions have placed
recovery efforts on hold white island is
about 30 miles off the coast the sky is
clear now but on Monday these boats were
packed with tourists fleeing the
erupting volcano many of them were
wounded some with severe burns Russell
Clark was one of the first responders on
the scene
can you imagine what it was like for the
people that were there at the time they
had nowhere to go in an absolute
terrible experience for them this
includes newlyweds Lauren and Matthew
URI who are now being treated in area
hospitals
Lauren spoke with her parents before
leaving on that hike I've had my
daughter now
that there was any risk involved she
wouldn't have gone and New Zealand's
Geoscience agency says that the coast is
still not clear there's a 50-50 chance
that a second eruption could happen in
just the next 24 hours meantime out in
the darkness white island is still
billowing toxic steam and ash Gale where
Amy thank you what a terrible story I
keep thinking how frightened they must
have been it seems like such a horrible
way to die you know I know it all
happens to us eventually death then you
just don't want to die terrified and
scared out of your mind and all these
people had on vacation these people had
nowhere to go thank you very much for
Amy reporting from New Zealand